yes so katie price appeared at crawley
magistrates court earlier today where
she did plead guilty to those three
charges it follows an incident where she
flipped her car over near her home in
sussex
at the time a police officer from sussex
police posted a picture of a car online
we can see the picture it's flipped over
we do now understand that car to be katy
prices
at the time sussex police also released
a statement where they said they'd
responded to reports of a single vehicle
collision near partridge green at around
6 20 on tuesday morning they say that a
woman was arrested there and had been
taken to hospital to be checked over now
we do understand that now to be katie
price and today in the magistrates court
her solicitor said that katie price has
been going through a difficult time
recently she's going through bankruptcy
proceedings her house may be repossessed
and that was echoed this morning by her
family who released a statement via
katie price's instagram account and in
that statement they say as a family we
have for some time been concerned about
kate's well-being and overall mental
health
today our worst fears nearly came true
as a family we have been and will
continue to help kate get the help she
needs we hope that she'll realize that
she cannot battle her issues alone
her family say that they acknowledge
that although katie price does live her
life in the public eye they hope that
she'll be given the time and space she
needs to battle her issues in private
earlier this week she appeared on
television giving an interview where she
acknowledged her driving ban and said it
was making it difficult to see her son
harvey who's in residential care in
cheltenham so a lot going on clearly for
the 43 year old who will be sentenced
for those three charges